Ce n'erano così tante ma così tante che ho dovuto per forza fare la seconda parte
Donne amiche ragazze soltanto per oggi in esclusiva per voi la faccina più irritante dell'intero emisfero boreale
L'OCCHIOLINO
Allora ragazze come ho fatto a dimenticarelo nello scorso video come ho potuto
come ho osato
allora quando un ragazzo ci risponde a un papiro o a un messaggino corto qualsiasi cosa un occhiolino
È proprio lì che non ci sentiamo prese per I fondelli
Ma stai scherzando?
Cioè tu pensi avere una benchè minima possibilità con me se invii l'occhiolino, l'occhiolino OUT proprio, non
Deve esistere per me non. È no è stra NO
ma non pensare che l'occhiolino sia l'unico
Appartenente alla categoria mi stai prendendo per il culo non osare e non permetterti mai più per  tutta la vita perché ci sono anche loro
C'è il sorrisone di cortesia più finto di temptation island è una cosa veramente cioè proprio è
insopportabile mi fa venire soltanto a pensarci la pelle d'oca dallo schifo c'è
Anche il sorrisino cioè praticamente la faccina con i denti di sopra e di sotto non ce l'ha è sdentato dalla nascita questo sorrisino anche
fintissimo non lo devi mai mandare in tutta la tua vita e poi c'è
Ma che cos'è l'ape Maia che cosa mi rappresenta
Cioè tu mi rispondi a un messaggio così io che cosa devo capire da questa cosa
che hai dei problemi
e ricordate quando vi
parlavo
Del famoso getto woods si si balla pecchia tu no vieni  ed era subito shalla e pugnetto?
molto bene
C'è un'altra emoji che è  sempre nell'ambito ghetto mood che è questa
fai lo sborrone
sei pieno di soldi   fai il riccone
Mah,oltre a questo ci sono anche tutte queste paghiamo a metà e fai lo splendido
C'è qualcosa che non quadra e qui signori e signora. Il rullo di tamburi. È il cuore in tutti I sensi del video
ed è
In questo momento più di annuncio l'uscita di un nuovo film che si chiama 50 sfumature di cuori
Nelle emoji ecco ragazzi perché fatte questa fatica allucinannte a inviarci  un cuore
Ufficiale il cuore ufficiale è rosso rosso dai tempi di adamo ed eva ecco perché
perché mi devi mandare uno di questi colori
Che cos'è il mondo di patty. Il cuore. Giallo cosa vuoi dirmi che sei geloso giallo come la, gelosia
perché verde verde speranza cioè
nero un pressaggio di morte
blu
Che cos'è un cuore estivo marino cioè per me è
definitivamente cento per cento
NO
Come ricordate la scorsa volta parlato del mood fai
la brava con l'angioletto e l'aureola ecco era tutto molto vario tutto molto evangelico ma infatti oggi vuole parlare dell'opposto quindi
Per. Il ragazzo che vuole sentirsi diavolo dentro il diavoletto
stronzetto il
Dio in pugno stai sulle spine ma c'è ma che cosa mi rappresenta
Questa cosa cioè perché me la mandi pensi di fare il piccolo stessa cosa per
mister maliziosetto cioè un emoji che si può usare travi che tra amici ma se stiamo portante della mani ma che cosa vuoi
farmi capire
Cosa che ci stai facendo pensiero è un doppio senza, del tutto molto yeah perché
Ma passiamo ad un'altra categoria la categoria di quei ragazzi che amano stupire chiamano. Le sorprese vedi tu stai parlando
Del più e del meno con lui è niente se ne esce con
Uno, dei 200 mila animali che ci sono tra le mogli
Possono essere, I più svariati il pesce palla il gamberetto
Il cammello cosa fai studi veterinaria e poi parlare dei tuoi interessi dei tuoi studi oppure
Lavori in un centro zoologico ecco non. Lo so forse una risposta il fatto
Che noi ragazze siamo messe di fronte veramente alle più svariate
opzioni cioè non riusciamo a capire perché si sta parlando di a e tutele chico di d'animo net
E parlando sempre dei ragazzi ci vogliono stupire
Invece di un mazzo di rose
le mose
ma ecco molto
sovrannaturale molto khyber
ci piace comunque sapere che avete rivisto logici
concludiamo questo video in bellezza con cui diamo alcuna nota romantica
Con delle mogli che ci lasciano sempre senza parole è quasi sempre dallo schifo
solo queste
Ci siamo passate tutte lo so nel momento difficile
Perché comunque chiudiamo completamente, I ponti con. Chi ce li manda e libertiamo
L'ha votato su tutti I social e momento difficile ma mi sarò vicino
Perché l'uomo che chiamando una di queste è un uomo che danno non riceverà neanche un emoticon
merito avete qualcosa da aggiungere
Io direi che parlano da sole eccoci arrivati alla fine? Del video secondo me con la prima parte la seconda parte. Ho
Elencato tutte secondo ci sono tutte quelle proprio che non ci devono inviare se video vi è piaciuto come sempre
mettete like e iscrivetevi alla mia pagina siamo sempre di più grazie mille diamo e
niente seguitemi anche sugli altri social facebook
instagram (SEGUITE LA MIA AMICA CHE HA AGGIUNTO I SOTTTOTITOLI E GLI EFFETTI @_giuliaferrante)
musicali mentre renzi che read this item
quella roba lì